today on the matt wall show horrifying
footage of a drag show for children at a
gay bar in texas over the weekend how is
this happening and how's it happening in
texas so we'll talk about that and one
bright spot in this story is the
protesters outside confronting and
shaming the groomers we need a lot more
of that also a criminal steals a car
runs over a mother and her child tries
to flee the scene and will now spend all
of
five months in juvenile detention for it
and a mother who rushed into rob
elementary to save her children while
police stood outside is speaking out
we'll listen to her story plus another
sneak peek of a scene from my film what
is a woman and our daily cancellation
we'd send screeners of the film to
mainstream film critics they responded
to our email and uh we're not happy
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matt well show
[Music]
you know abortion has been of course in
the news with the impending roe v wade
decision and uh it's going to be even
more so once eventually this decision
comes out
and if they decide to get rid of roe v
wade which i think they will
you may think it means that the fight is
coming to an end but abortion
legislation returning to the states
means that the real battle is really
just beginning and there's no group in
america better positioned than 40 days
for life to help fight this battle 40
days for life has 1 million volunteers
throughout the country holding peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities may
be surprised to hear that their largest
presence is actually in the country's
bluest states with california
being their biggest state actually their
vigils have closed many abortion
facilities in america and nearly half of
those facilities were in liberal states
where abortion will continue to remain
legal after the fall of roe from san
francisco to chicago to seattle hardly
pro-life areas as i'm sure you know
volunteers have guided abortion workers
to have a change of heart and quit their
jobs so as this issue gets out of dc
finally 40 days for life is effectively
changing hearts and minds in the
grassroots of the pro-abortion movement
you can check out their locations
podcast and their new book what to say
when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion at 40daysforlife.com
one reason that i've always been kind of
skeptical about any predictions of a
coming civil war is that most americans
don't have the energy or attention span
to fight a civil war would require too
much time away from the couch in netflix
but the other reason for my skepticism
is that some boundaries between the
sides are not nearly as geographically
defined and delineated as they were in
say 1861 for the first round
we speak broadly of red states and blue
states and um we think of the left as
living in coastal metropolises while the
right lives down south and across the
heartland but this of course is a
massive oversimplification and even more
pressingly however apart from any civil
war discussion
the idea that there are these wide
swaths of conservative geographic
dominance can lead to
i think a kind of false sense of
contentment and security among
conservatives
they say well leave the cities leave
california leave new york and move down
south and you'll be free of the moral
filth and insanity infecting those
places
that's what we seem to think
but the reality is a lot more
complicated and also unfortunately more
depressing
after all
texas is one of the places that's
supposed to be a kind of promised land
for conservatives and yet texas is where
this happened over the weekend from the
daily wire it says a dallas gay bar is
under fire for hosting an afternoon drag
show for children saturday where kids
were invited on stage and tipped
performers in front of a neon sign
bearing an obscene message
the drag the kids to pride show at the
mr mister bar
was billed as a family-friendly version
of the bar's regular champagne drag
brunch during saturday's event drag
performers danced with and took dollar
bills from some of the children
according to abc affiliate wfaa
um do you want to hit the stage with the
queens reads a promotion for the event
we have five limited spots for young
performers to take the stage solo or
with a queen of their choosing
now the obscene message on that neon
sign by the way said it's not going to
lick itself so the sign said and we can
fairly assume that this was not a
reference to uh an ice cream cone in
fact
we know that the environment the event
and everything associated with it was
highly sexualized in nature because
first it's a drag show and second it's
at a gay club
this means that the event was
not only morally abominable but also by
the way illegal like explicitly illegal
in fact it's illegal on several levels
including by the clear language of a
bill passed just last year in texas
sb 315 forbids quote sexually oriented
businesses
from allowing any patrons under the age
of 21 on to the premises
and this was a this was a bill that was
actually written to to rate because
before it was you had to be 18 or over
and so they made it to they raised the
age so you got to be 21 or over
um
the kids that were in that drag
at this drag event weren't even close to
18 let alone 21.
the same bill um also explicitly forbids
any business from engaging in activities
quote harmful to a child so this would
this would seem to be legislation
like written to stop events like the one
in dallas
there's no question that a gay club is a
sexual sexually oriented business
and if you did have a question about
that the bright glowing enormous neon
sign with a sexual reference posted
right on the wall by the door for
everyone to see
should answer the question
so
was the bar shut down license revoked
that's what the bill says is supposed to
happen that's the consequence
were the employees and parents and all
the other adults involved arrested
shackled and frog marched to jail
no in fact following the uh recent trend
texas cops stood outside and did nothing
well not nothing they did harass
protesters who'd shown up to voice their
displeasure at the blatant sexual
exploitation of children that was going
on inside the establishment we'll have
more on that in just a moment first
let's let's just take a look at um what
actually happened in this drag your
child to pride event there's plenty of
footage of this atrocity and it's clear
that much of the event consisted of
cross-dressing men in their burlesque
outfits dancing for children while the
children were encouraged to hand the
dancers
dollar bills you know like
like they do at strip clubs
here take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now it gets worse somehow the children
were also included in the performance as
the daily wire article alluded to um
compelled to be active participants
at a certain point the drag queens
brought the kids up on stage and coached
them on how to walk the runway i mean
it's like literal grooming happening
in front of the crowd the kids of course
appeared confused and bewildered by the
whole thing
watch
[Applause]
everybody
go with me who wants to go first you
want to go with me all right this is my
partner
you ready to do this
on the count of three here we go
one
walk for me walk for me let's go
[Applause]
um okay so
and it's it's the reason it's all blurry
and looks smoky in there is that we we
wanted to blur it so you couldn't see
the kids but you could still see what
was happening
to them what was being done
you'll notice
how the adults the parents are
way more excited about this than the
children in fact the first uh little boy
up on up up there that was brought up
there
to participate he
obviously doesn't want to be there i
mean he's got he's he's kind of like
hunched over and he's doing the thing
that kids always do and they don't want
to do something just kind of walking
sort of that kind of hunched over thing
um
doesn't want to be there
of course he doesn't want to be there
he's he's a boy like he's it looks like
his six or seven year old boy wants to
be outside playing he wants to
you know he wants to be uh uh playing
with his superhero action figures do
whatever doing whatever he wants he
doesn't want to be there doing that
but that's why they call it
drag the kids to pride right that's the
name of the event it's a name so on the
nose that at first when i saw that name
and the images with the with the flyer
and everything to promote the event i
thought honestly it was a meme invented
by the right
drag the kids to pride
no it turns out that's actually the name
they used
and indeed the kids were dragged into
this by parents who if it's possible to
rank the villains in this situation
would certainly take the title as the
biggest scumbags now the degenerate bar
owner who hosted this event the
cross-dressers who strutted around for a
bunch of elementary schoolers are all
demonic filth as well of course but
parents have a special responsibility to
love and protect their children sitting
back sipping booze and cheering as your
child is sexually exploited is a level
of evil that's just it's hard to
comprehend for anybody especially if
you're a parent
in fact we got some insight into the
parent-child dynamic from a journalist
named taylor hanson who uh made his way
into the event so that he could film it
and expose what was going on and after
enduring what had to be a
traumatic experience even for an adult
who has to watch this i mean imagine
what the kids are are feeling
he shared one exchange that he witnessed
between a mother child and a bartender i
want you to listen to this
they have a kid sitting there at the bar
as well
and he's sitting there with his face you
know plugged into his nintendo ds 3ds he
doesn't care about the drag stars
doesn't care about anything going on
there his mom's trying to get him to pay
attention he doesn't care still playing
his games and the uh i overheard a
conversation that was really startling
it was uh he was talking to the
bartender and he said no i'm not gay
and his mom butted in interrupted this
child and said no he is gay don't let
him lie to you he is
and the kid you could just tell he was
super uncomfortable he obviously wasn't
gay but his mom's telling everyone he's
gay and he just sat there and played
nintendo the entire time and i mean he
worked on a rubik's cube as well i
watched this kid solve the same rubik's
cube
three times i mean he didn't care to be
there didn't care about anything going
on and meanwhile you have the parents on
the other side of the aisle giving their
kids money they're wearing trans lives
matter shirts they're wearing all of
these shirts that they don't even know
what it means but just because their mom
told them that it would look nice
now normally i hate it when kids are you
know immersed in their phones and
screens and they won't look up from the
screen
in this case though it was the child's
saving grace in fact sadly the the only
hope that this young boy has is that he
will just ignore his horrible manchester
mother remain totally disinterested in
whatever she's trying to force him into
and then perhaps later in life rebel
against her as many teens do rebel
except in this case he'd be rebelling
against moral insanity by choosing to be
sane rational and decent
and that would break his mother's heart
more than anything i mean if he
his mother if he ends up being a sane
rational morally decent well-adjusted
person that would break her heart and i
pray to god that her heart is broken in
that way
this mother deserves to be in solitary
confinement for the rest of her life as
do all the adults involved
but if we can't get that then hopefully
at least they'll be punished when their
children realize what monstrous ghouls
they are and cut them out of their lives
forever
we can pray for such a result but we
also know from a pure statistical
standpoint that
many of these children are
statistically a certain percentage of
them are doomed i mean are going to be
sucked into this there's a chance that a
child who grows up in this environment
will still grow to be good and happy
people but
it's not a very great chance
and that's the tragedy of it
of course the left has come up with
different ways of excusing all this but
the excuses always eventually filter
back down to the simple truth of the
matter
um at first because his thing with the
left at any time they're making an
argument
or they're defending something
um the first thing they say the first
defense they offer
it's always like it's always well here's
how i'll defend this
but even if what i'm saying right now
isn't true then then whatever i'm
defending is still okay that's kind of
how it works so at first they've tried
to claim that there's nothing sexual
about any of this it's all totally
innocent and family-friendly
yet this rationale doesn't stand up to
scrutiny because drag is hypersexual by
its nature that's the point of the thing
also they're at a gay bar and there's
the dollar bills the dancers are being
handed and then there's the neon sign
with the sexually explicit message right
there in front of the kids
all of this precludes any attempt to
pretend that this is anything but sexual
and that's when the apologists pivot
from
it's not sexual to it's sexual but
that's good
they say it's healthy for children to be
exposed to this sort of thing it'll make
them more tolerant and open-minded and
progressive
but the point is not really to make them
open-minded of course even if that was
the point that would not even begin to
excuse what's happening but as gk
chesterton said the object of opening
the mind
is to close it again around something
and hopefully what you're doing is
you're opening the mind to close it
around truth
in this case they're closing the mind
around perversion and depravity
now do they want to sexualize these
children just for the sake of it to
fulfill their pedophilic fantasies well
certainly there's a lot of that going on
yes but
also the goal is to you know quote
unquote liberate the child from any
semblance of traditional morality it's
to wall him off from moral truth from
reality itself really
the adults want these children to grow
up and become the same sorts of feckless
confused deviants that they are
and that's why i take some solace in in
the one bright spot
of everything that happened around that
bar in dallas and that would be the
protesters out front
confronting and shaming the groomers one
of them is alex stein who confronted a
drag queen
in the parking lot uh as he was leaving
let's watch
that little children do you like dancing
for little children
you don't think that's disgusting
dancing around for a little time away
from me don't you think that's
disgusting i need you to do something
away you can't just touch me you don't
think that you could do it to me your
mom's
go on that's disgusting
dancing for little children you should
be
you should be ashamed of yourself
dancing for little children you should
be ashamed of yourself
you should be ashamed of yourselves
you're disgusting think about what you
just did
okay that's fine but you danced naked in
front of little children
you did you did
very well done um by by alex there
now
not everyone may be comfortable with
that sort of thing you know the
confrontational approach
there are still conservatives who aren't
comfortable with it who say i don't know
about that that makes me well if you're
not comfortable with it you need to get
comfortable um these people have been
operating in a world
free of shame right that's that's the
world they've kind of that's the bubble
that they've constructed for themselves
which which is why uh they they were
not only put this event on
and not only in texas
but were shocked that protesters were
outside shocked and
scandalized and offended
they didn't think anybody would would
come and have a problem with it
and only in this kind of shameless
bubble
could child drag shows exist in the
first place
that's why we have to we have to bring
shame back
and direct it in the places where it
belongs
that was always a lie that there's that
is wrong you know shame is wrong it's
wrong to shame things shame people
no shame is a good tool
as long as you're shaming the things
that need to be shamed shaming the
things that are shameful
expose confront shame
now it'd be better if the people in
charge would just enforce the law and
protect our children
but they won't
so
it's up to us
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right i hope you had a good uh
weekend i i just know mine was active i
started the weekend
actually on friday in denver to speak at
the western conservative summit out
there then i flew down that night for
the tpusa women's leadership conference
where i had a conversation with charlie
kirk on stage about the film that was
great and then i flew up to uh virginia
to see family for a day then back to
nashville and i got back to my house
and while i was gone the whole time i
had some some
bees
delivered to my house because i'm
getting back into the beekeeping game
and so someone dropped off a couple of
hives and you know like left them in the
yard
and but i had to uh i had to
put them they weren't where they needed
to be because they're like right next to
the house i had to put them like bring
them up a hill to what to the what we
call the b yard where i want my beehives
to be
and um you know usually when you buy a
package of bees it comes in like a kind
of a small box and there's like 3000
bees and you could really lift it with
one arm you probably shouldn't but you
could in this case i had full hives that
were delivered
and i had to move them
up a hill
by myself and i'd never really moved a
full hive before
and i thought to myself before i did it
that i should probably look up online
maybe a youtube video on how exactly
this process is supposed to work but
then i thought that will take time and
i'd be bored so instead i'll just go out
there and do it
and so i went out i picked up these
giant boxes full of like 10 000 bees and
i like carry them up a hill at one point
i kind of partially tripped in this
divot this little ditch in the in the
grass
and i almost dropped the bees and the
thing is if i had done that i would have
dropped them and then fallen into them
and i didn't but i almost did
and all i could think about
after that happened
was that man if i was killed
from falling into a beehive
right now of all times
that would be so many people would be so
happy
i can't allow that to happen and and the
other thing that would be unfortunate is
that i have to think about this kind of
thing now that like even my supporters
because i know that if i die of course
the left's gonna be happy they'll be
making fun of me but but i have to think
about the fact that my supporters if i
die like in an embarrassing way by
falling into a beehive and getting stung
to death
um they would have my supporters would
have to even have to admit that i died
in a way that was a little a little bit
goofy
so this is the pressure that i have on
me now
i know that when i die people will
celebrate so i have to make sure that i
don't die
in an embarrassing way like for your
sake in the sweet baby gang i have to
give you a noble or at least tragic
death
so something to think about but it all
it all worked out okay the bees are
where they need to be um
i want to start with this bill mulligan
at fox news has a story
here first i want to show you the video
it's a quick video
uh yet another
disturbing video unfortunately but i'll
just tell you
the good news here is that what you're
about to see
both of the victims did did survive
but this was a woman in california who
was hit by a car
while she was walking her child in a
stroller and uh let's just let's go
ahead and play that so we see that
footage here
okay so she's walking she tries to get
over to the side and then this car
looks like it's swerving at her
now i want you to watch what happens
next
car drives away hit and run
and then look at this guy in the pickup
truck now here's this is actually heroic
so the guy in the pickup truck
sacrifices his car like gets into a
head-on collision intentionally to stop
the
person in the car that just did the hit
and run
um
so you know that that's
the person that pickup truck deserves
lots of credit for that also the mom you
know you you watch that video there and
it's very upsetting obviously you see a
mom and her baby getting hit by a car we
also see how the mom
as the car is coming and she realizes
she can't get out of the way she she
pivots around
and puts herself in front of her child
so that she takes the brunt of the
impact and then she gets hit by a car
and rolls off the you know rolls off the
hood of the car and then immediately
pops up and goes to check on her child
and again fortunately thank god both the
um
mother and child were
were okay now here's the full story all
right
and this is we go to bill mulligan who's
got the full story
he reports a 16 year old hit and run
driver in a stolen car who ran over a
mom and child in venice
was sentenced on friday to five to seven
months in juvie camp
um d.a george gascon office tells me
that this was an appropriate resolution
but i've learned he was a prior he has a
prior criminal history per multiple law
enforcement sources the juve was on
probation and violating it at the time
of this hit-and-run and he has been
previously convicted of felony poisoning
after he spiked a teen girl's drink at
palmdale high school in 2019.
she was hospitalized despite the
jubilee's criminal history sources in
the last days da's office tell me that
in accordance with his policies gascon's
admin didn't charge the juve with
assault with a deadly weapon or
attempted murder for the hit and run
which led to this light sentence
so that is not assault with a deadly
weapon
running a mother and her child in a
stroller over with a hitting them with a
car is not assault with a deadly weapon
now actually as it turns out i mean for
all the talk we hear about a so-called
assault rifles whatever those are
supposed to be
cars are much statistically much
deadlier weapons than our quote-unquote
assault rifles
so this uh this d.a this is what this is
what he does i mean this is the same d.a
i believe who um
you know there was that trans
pedophile who there's so many cases like
this it's hard to even point pinpoint
one but it just just
this is what he does takes dangerous
terrible people and makes sure to keep
putting them back on the street he wants
to keep as many of them out on the
street as possible
and it would be bad enough a five to
seven month sentence but then you look
at this this
i hesitate to even call him a kid but he
is 16. uh you look at his criminal
history
now let's ask ourselves you've got a 16
year old
who already has a history
of criminal violence
he poisoned somebody and now he's
stealing a car
running a woman over her and her baby
and trying to run
so you give him another seven months
just kind of like hanging out with other
juvenile delinquents is he going to come
out and be and be magically better is he
going to come out and
be reformed is that all it's going to
take
no obviously not
because as they filter these people
through the system
all they're just getting worse and worse
okay so it's not even it's not even
neutral where you just take an offender
and then you throw them back out on the
street and they're just as dangerous as
they were before no
this is being done in a way to make them
more dangerous
number one because they're being
emboldened
not being held accountable
and the message that's being sent
especially to this kid over and over
again is you can do whatever you want
and there will be almost no consequence
so you're emboldening them and also
you're just kind of like hooking them up
with
other delinquents and criminals and
violent people
so it becomes nothing more it's like
it's like setting them off for a social
gathering for a few months with other
delinquents and then you toss them back
out on the street
and you keep doing this until this kid
kills somebody and he will
it's a miracle he hasn't already not for
lack of trying he's gonna kill somebody
eventually and it's like we know that
everyone knows that this
d.a gascon this marxist d.a he knows
that dude doesn't care
and his message to the community and all
the innocent people and the women that
this that this kid's going to victimize
and already has victimized
is uh well look too bad
we care more about this criminal than we
do about you
and why is it i mean why what what
really i mean
why are we doing this
why not just take him and put him in
prison
for a long period of time
protect the innocent people that he's
victimized victimizing
this this would seem to be an easy win
for especially a d.a
you've got a mother and her child in a
stroller hit by a car
throw the book at the scumbag
everybody would celebrate that
so it's not only the right thing to do
morally and logically and legally but it
would also be the most politically
popular thing to do so why wouldn't you
do it
well one answer is that these are these
are
marxists this is a marxist d.a this is
this is another um
you know hand-picked uh george soros
puppet
and they simply hate civilization
they really do
they they want to destabilize
civilization
and also on top of that um not that i
want to let them off the hook by you
know letting them claim ignorance but it
is also true that because of their
ideological commitments they do not
understand human nature at all
they just don't understand it
they think of people as like blank
slates
that you can just
you know you could just kind of slap
them on the wrist and say don't do that
anymore and then they'll just stop doing
it kind of like flipping a switch or
something reprogramming
doesn't work that way
i mean human nature tells us
that when someone starts to
descend into evil
you know that descent is going to
continue unless something is done
something drastic has done to stop it
and the other part of human nature is
that we know that although it's it's it
is possible for people to be redeemed
it's possible for them to repent it's
possible for them to reform and change
their lives one thing we know is that
it's never going to happen
unless there's no chance of it unless
they're forced to confront the horrible
things that they've done like you you
cannot actually
um repent of a sin that you haven't
confronted you if you don't understand
the severity of it if you're not if
you're not forced into this
confrontation with your own sin and the
own and your own evil that you've
committed there's not going to be any
repentance there's no chance of it
and that's that's one aspect and the
other aspect is that um
although it is possible
for someone to reform most people
don't the chances of it are very low if
you've got a kid who's not even 18 yet
he's already poisoning people and
running people over with cars
99 chance unfortunately is that he's
going to be a dangerous scumbag for the
rest of his life
you hope for some reformation but
probably not going to happen
statistically which means that for the
sake of society
you need to segregate him from everybody
else
i want to move to this um i don't know
if this is so much a headline but uh but
it's a headline for me i um
i want to show you another quick sneak
peek this is something that i posted on
twitter a couple days ago quick sneak
peek from the film and this relates to
you know everything we talked about
really in the opening
um
the it's sort of the logical conclusion
of the leftist
sexual
agenda what what happens when we become
unmoored from truth onward from reality
from our moral
tradition and we uh took the rabbit hole
all the way down in the film so i want
to play this clip from what is woman
which is available now at what is
woman.com you can become a subscriber
and watch but here it is watch
so now we are seeing kids that are
identifying as animals going to school
and they are purring instead of
answering questions and they meow and
the teachers are not allowed to question
it because it's considered a queer
identity
so
you have kids are going to school and
they're saying i'm a cat
and the teachers have to
affirm them as a cat
yes so it's not just
literal
[Laughter]
i am a 27 year old transgender woman
i am a wolf therian and a member of the
furry fandom when and how did you
discover this inner wolf-ness um
probably around age 10 or 11. i was
watching
an anime about wolves and
see the wolf running across the screen
and i'm somehow just intrinsically like
oh that's me have you spent any time
around biological wolves yes
that sounds dangerous also what context
are you so i was a volunteer with the
preserve and i've also visited many wolf
preserves are you able to communicate
with the wolves am i going to have a
conversation with a wolf in the way that
i'm communicating you and i obviously
not am i going to read their body
language respond appropriately to their
behaviors and their nonverbal cues yes
would you would you be able to give us
an example of
this wolf communication um no
i'm not comfortable doing so okay all
right
i mean i thought i'd ask anyone
uh i would be interested to know i mean
i i still would would like to know what
um
really what the interpersonal
communication between a wolf is like and
you and you see that and you think well
that's uh absurd and you can kind of
laugh about it and sure but
you know i'm telling you right now this
is not uh
this is not any kind of
um
[Music]
extreme slippery slope
possibility i think that
a few years from now that someone i
don't know if it's gonna be me but
someone's gonna have to make a film
called what is a human because
this trans species stuff this is not
um just a fringe
fad
you know outlier type of thing
this as we heard from sarah stockton
who's the therapist in the first part of
that clip
this is a very common thing
and she's not the only one saying that
you know you hear people that work in
the schools therapists that feel like
they can speak out without be having
their careers destroyed that this is
this is the thing now
the kids this is what kids are doing
and it's like well and of course kids
are doing that
when you tell kids that hey you could be
whatever you want to be your identity is
up to you of course a lot of them are
going to say
oh well i'm a i'm a wolfer i'm a
whatever i'm a monkey
and and usually
in like an insane society kids
pretending to be animals as long as
they're kids now the person we were
talking to there the was it wolf therian
not a kid that's an adult but for kids
pretending to be animals usually it's uh
my own kids do that sometimes
my two-year-old runs around pretending
to be now and that's that's perfectly
fine that's using your imagination
except that we don't live in a sane
society and so now uh we latch on to
that and say okay well that that's your
right that's who you are now that's your
identity
that's not just a game that's who you
are
so look out for the sequel what is a
human dropping sometime in the next few
years
um i'm going to move to this
dailymail says um at least 50 people are
feared dead after a gunman opened fire
on worshipers and detonated explosives
at a catholic church in southwestern
nigeria on sunday
the violence at saint francis catholic
church in
our town happened during the morning
service on pentecost sunday in a rare
attack in the southwest of the african
country
um
and
i i i'm pretty sure that the body count
has gone up from 50 but they're but you
know they're talking about at least 50
people were killed in this attack
obviously a terrible tragedy horrible
massacre um
and it comes just a week or so after we
heard over and over again
and we addressed this on the show we
heard this this is they made this claim
on the view and plenty of other places
in media
that
this kind of thing only happens in
america this this is a uniquely american
problem
and you'll remember i said well that's
ridiculous it happens everywhere
um
and here is
tragic evidence of that
not not but a few days later
what we find and the reason why this is
important to point out is that is that's
a violence and death
that's a universe like universal human
condition
it goes down to human nature
which is why it's so important if you're
a d.a or if you're anybody else it's
important to understand human nature
now there's um a poll that was done by
cbs and it's it's
viral right now the results are viral on
twitter right now because
it's being seen by the left as an
opportunity to dunk on republicans
because here's the here's the headline
um
from yahoo news four in 10 republicans
think mass shootings are unfortunately
something we have to accept as part of a
free society
and then it continues in the article
there's more than 410 republicans think
mass shootings are inevitable in a free
society survey results came on the heels
of a string of mass shootings one of the
questions in the poll asked residents if
they feel that mass shootings are
unfortunately something we have to
accept
or something we can prevent and stop if
we really tried in in response 44 of
republicans said mass shootings are
inevitable as part of a free society now
of course the left is oh how could they
possibly say that they're okay with mass
shootings
that doesn't mean you're okay with it
obviously
nobody no one outside of the actual mass
shooters are okay with mass shootings
everyone agrees it's a horrible thing
the only my only disagreement
with um the republicans the four and 10
republicans that responded this way
although they're just responding to the
poll in the way that it's worded my only
disagreement is that it says you know
mass shootings are inevitable in a free
society no no
this is inevitable in any society free
or not
and if it's not mass shootings then it's
mass slaughter and mass attacks of other
kinds
it's inevitable
there's never going to be a time
never
when we will have rid the world of
murder
it is never going to happen
now does that mean that you're okay with
people being murdered obviously not
it just means that you're confront you
want to live in reality you want to
start
you want to have your starting point in
reality
because if you're going to protect
yourself and notice that these
respondents they didn't say well there's
nothing we can do to protect ourselves
there's nothing we can do to punish the
people to do it there's nothing that we
can do to defend our children they
didn't say any of that
but if you want to protect yourself
and defend your family and yourself and
your children then you have to have a
starting point of reality which is to
recognize
that there is always the potential of
this kind of thing happening
you recognize that so that you can have
a chance of preventing some of it
um
and that's that's why
uh
you know you want to be able to have the
ability to protect yourself rather than
relying on you know rather than sitting
back and say well i'll wait for the
government to come up with some kind of
plan
so some legislation some policy that uh
that will protect me and my family and
just make all this go go away
that's the leftist approach and that's
how they
answer these surveys
so they can somehow feel that they're on
a
kind of they could purge themselves on a
higher moral
vantage point they think
you say i'm more opposed to to mass
shootings than you are no no you're not
but you can't be you can't really be
opposed to anything in reality if you're
not living there first
um understanding the inevitability of
these kinds of things is how you is how
you can actually work to prevent some of
it
um
you know death in general is an
inevitability
i don't like it no one likes that fact
but that's that is also a fact of
reality and you have to
again if you want to be able to protect
yourself you have to start from that
reality
um
now speaking of this this is from the
blaze i wanted to play this for you it
says a texas mother who devi who defied
uvalde police officers and ran into the
school during the mass shooting to save
her children has come forward to tell
her story despite alleged threats by law
enforcement for her not to speak to the
media on the morning of may 24th
um anjali gomez went to rob elementary
school to see her kids graduation
ceremonies
uh and
she
and then
she found out what was happening there
she rushes to the school then we have
the local media they did an interview
with this with this mother and i think
this clip's about two minutes but she
talks about everything that happened and
it's worth listening to
right away as i parked um us marshall
started coming toward my car saying that
i wasn't allowed to be parked there and
he said well we're gonna have to arrest
you because you're being very
uncooperative i said well you're gonna
have to arrest me because i'm going in
there and i'm telling you right now i
don't see none of y'all in there y'all
are standing with snipers and y'all are
far away i'm if y'all don't go in there
i'm going in there he
immediately put me in cubs she says
after ivaldi police officers told
marshalls to uncuff gomez she ran
towards the school as soon as they uncut
me i jumped that first gate fence and
once i jumped it i went to my son's
class
and then knocked on the door and i
remember the teacher saying um i'm like
hey they're already they're already um
bulge cutting the fence to get me she's
like you think we have time to get out
he said you have time i'm gonna run for
my other son once she was assured her
son was okay gomez ran to get her other
child encountering more officers who
tried to stop her so i start yelling and
i'm being a cooperative and i'm like
well y'all aren't doing what are y'all
doing
y'all need to be in here give me your
best somebody give me a bet some
something i started paying attention to
how far the shots were being so that i
knew the shooter was all the way still
by my first son's class so when i went
to my set my second friend's door the
teacher didn't want to open the door for
me so that's when they started um
escorting me out and as
i see that they're opening my son's door
i go run for my son and i get him with
both of her kids out safe gomez still
can't shake the thought of those who
didn't make it while you were inside the
school did you see
officers there inside this officer
inside the school when i ran into your
second son's class there was not one
officer and you were hearing gun shots
so you knew you could hear that it was
an active shot it was still active the
gunshots were still active they were not
in there there was no one in there if
anything when i pulled up my car was
closer to the school than that than
where the snipers and everybody that was
laying on the ground were
and somehow
people on the left will see this that
clip as many of them have been sharing
it
you know on social media good reason to
share it it's a it's a powerful
harrowing also infuriating story at the
same time
but they'll see it and not draw the
connection between this and the gun
issue
you can't rely on the government to
protect you
as is clearly the case here
get rid of the guns and that's what
you're left with
you're left hoping that the government
will that government employees will step
up and protect you and maybe sometimes
they will but it's pretty clear you
can't depend on it
so she ran in to save her her child and
and both of her children rather
um
and in a significant detail that we
heard there is that as she is running
from class to class
to say you know running into
what as far she knew gunfire
unarmed to save both of her children but
as she's doing that she hears the gun
shot the gunfire continued
and that's a really
important point because
one of the defenses or excuses that has
been offered
by and for the sake of the police
officers is that well by the time they
got there the shooting had stopped
and even if that was true that still
would not even begin to excuse the fact
that they let the shooter stay in there
for an hour
but that's not true he this this uh
scumbag
this demon
was in that classroom with the kids and
just slowly
executing them one by one over the
course of an hour while the police were
outside
that's what happened
cannot
rely
on anyone to defend us or our families
that's just
the truth of the matter
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
uh let's see abby says the real star of
the movie is mrs walsh sorry matt first
of all spoiler warning uh second no need
to apologize um
very happy we could uh include her in
the film and uh
i thought it was a
well i don't want to give it away so
you're just all these spoilers people
are not uh
respecting that
mike says
matt loved your film but the one really
big omission is that the film never
mentions god or grounds itself in the
truth of scripture
massive missed opportunity
um
yeah i've i've heard this critique of a
couple different places i i just really
disagree with it quite a bit
um
the objective of the film is first of
all to expose the absurdity and the
hollowness of gender ideology
and to kind of re and and to show how
this is being
you know how kids are being
indoctrinated how this is harming people
harming women harming everybody to
expose all of that
and then to reassert basic common sense
reality
you know um the the answer to what okay
i just said i want to give spoiler
spoilers away but the answer to what is
a woman is adult female
so i'm not sure what
by the end of it we finally get to the
answer and you would have liked it to be
what a bible quote or
a woman is someone who's created by god
or something like that the thing is of
course that's true
but if you if if we had done that
the left would have been very happy i
could tell you that
okay if we had framed this
in a in a religious context
the left would love that that's what
they were hoping this movie would be
and it's not that's one of the reasons
why they're so afraid of it
um
i think we need to we need to start with
the basic reality
it's like if somebody says um
if someone's going around if there's a
movement of people going around claiming
that two plus two equals five
okay we're going to destroy mathematics
two plus two equals five
what's your response to that gonna be
your response is gonna be no no it's
four you're not gonna say well no god
says that two plus two equals four he
does but that's no one would you
wouldn't that would be a response nobody
would say that
that would not be the the
most effective response because then
you're making it seem like
your belief in mathematics is rooted in
religious faith it's like a religious
doctrine no it's just math
yes everything comes from god including
mathematics
and that's a conversation we can have
once you've reasserted the basic reality
okay someone says two plus two equals
five you don't immediately pull out the
bible and start and start flipping
through scripture no start with no no it
equals four
let's start there
and then we could go deeper into a lot
of different issues the other thing keep
in mind with what is a woman is that
it's one film it's 90 minutes so i have
heard from people um
you know and i appreciate everyone's
feedback but i have heard from people
say well why don't you talk more about
this why don't you go that direction
all those things are important like
there are you know there are 50
different movies that could be made
based on the various different avenues
that we went down
and we should we should do all those
things
um
other people can make movies about those
things and we can talk about all those
subjects
but you gotta you have a you have to
have a starting point
all right let's see
uh leave it be says gender being a
feeling is ridiculous every single
person is going to feel different from
what society deems womanly or feminine
manly or masculine by their standards
everyone on earth would have a unique
gender identity this documentary was
amazing
uh yeah what you're also getting at is
is and this is what kind of what we
heard from jordan peterson in the film
that there's this conflation of gender
and personality or gender and
temperament
and and a lot of the times when people
are talking about gender that's actually
what they're trying to describe
so we've kind of kind of thrown you
notice that too people don't talk about
personality and temperament that much
anymore
because the word gender has
subsumed all of that
let's see
what else we have
tercio says matt's poker face reaction
to the insanity threw them off that's
probably how he got them to admit such
horrible things on camera they don't
expect you to listen they want you to
either to applaud without really
questioning anything or to disagree with
them up front so they can dismiss you as
a bigot but they don't know how to
handle a person actually paying
attention to what they have to say they
don't know what to do so they just kept
talking and revealing their horrifying
secrets yeah there's that of course they
yes they want they want to be as we've
talked about they want to be immediately
affirmed they want to be you know they
want you to just submit to whatever
they're saying and not along but the
other thing
is that they they don't want to have to
say very much right so on any of these
subjects they have a couple of sentences
they have like their talking point
their party line and they're happy to
give you that and to say a couple of
sentences but that's all they got
they don't want to have to continue
talking
and what i found in doing the film is
that
yeah you got to ask the right questions
although it's not hard to
figure out which questions to ask
because the most basic questions in the
world
but sometimes
even more important than the question
is just the silence
which is why there's a lot of awkward
silence and pauses in these interviews
um and some of that is just like it just
is kind of hilarious but also
no if you ask the question
they give you their kind of
one-off talking point answer
and they just
leave more keep
say nothing let them keep talking
don't don't bail them out by saying
something else you know offering your
own perspective asking a different
question like no just
yes continue let's hear more about that
and then when you do that you find that
there
isn't much more to say as it turns out
all right let's get now to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
the movie review aggregation site rotten
tomatoes doesn't always give the most
accurate impression of a film's
uh you know quality for anybody
unfamiliar with the site if you are the
the idea is that all the reviews of a
film are compiled and categorized as
generally positive or generally negative
and then we're given a percentage score
so a movie with a positive percentage
above 60 is fresh
um ostensibly if the positive percentage
is higher 70 80 90 it's supposed to be
pretty good assurance that the film is
you know very high quality
the problem is that a film which most
critics found just mildly amusing might
end up with a 95 fresh score simply
because 95 of critics were mildly amused
by it so the 95 is a bit misleading in
that case as we tend to associate 95
with an a plus grade but the rotten
tomatoes grading system in effect makes
it so that a whole bunch of c minuses
can add up to an a-plus this is how
every marvel movie passes as critically
acclaimed for example
the other problem is that
film critics are some of the most
shameless and dishonest shills in media
which is really saying something so a
very good film that fails to pass the
woke litmus test may end up with a 30 or
40 percent
in those cases it can be enlightening as
people know to look at the audience
score and compare it because rotten
tomatoes also allows regular joes to
leave their reviews and their rating on
a one to five star scale
frequently movies that are panned for
political reasons will have a very
lopsided review ratio maybe he's got 30
from critics but a 90 from audiences and
if you see something like that you know
almost every time that the film is
probably pretty decent
sometimes it'll go the other way and a
film will have a 90 percent from critics
and um a 30 from audiences this usually
means that the movie is this kind of
like meandering pointless art house
tripe that critics pretended to like so
they would seem smart
all in all
a lot can be gleaned from a comparison
of the two percentages
so
what can we learn from this
as of last night my new film what is a
woman had earned a 97 score from the
audience with well over a thousand
reviews counted
which is a lot of reviews by the way
from from audiences so there are a lot
of big box office
films that uh don't get a thousand
reviews in the first week as we did 97
what score did it get from the critics
well n a not applicable there's no score
they just haven't reviewed it none of
them there's one critic review and it's
from christian toto who's a great
contributor for the daily wire
outside of that though the movie has
been completely and totally ignored by
the media
why haven't they watched it it's not
it's not that they're panning it they're
just not they're refusing to watch it
and why is it because they they don't
know about it or they don't have time to
watch it or just they don't think it's
very important or whatever
well they might be able to make that
claim
if not for the fact that we sent the
screener to media critics and many of
them responded
to the email that we sent them telling
us in so many words to go f ourselves
actually in those words exactly in some
cases so let me read through a few of
the responses that we got from film
critics um
one says unsubscribe unsubscribe
unsubscribe unsubscribe unsubscribe
continuing infinity another one says
unsubscribe lose my email forget my name
uh another one says hard effing pass i
won't give that transphobic bigot a
platform on my site never email me again
another hard pass
uh another one says absolutely i think
not he's a bigot you should be ashamed
for associating with him
another one please remove it from remove
me from your mailing list i am not
interested in anything having to do with
matt walsh
another one says big no thanks
um
let's see yeah i'm not reviewing a film
by a bigot and if that's how who you
work with you can take me off your list
i won't be reviewing anything from you
uh another one says please don't send me
anything else from the daily wire i'm
not interested
and then we got a bunch of uh
this one was good okay here's one says
hi trans woman here
just got your email inquiring if i
wanted to review your nazi transphobic
movie in the future please send requests
like requests like this to d's dsnuts
gmail.com now
i don't think this person realizes that
the last part of their email
in the first part
hi i'm a woman
send the request to d's nuts
all right um
and then another one says take me off
your list i'm not interested in covering
content from fear-mongering people whose
inc inquiries into gender and identity
are predicated on the basis of taking
rights away from people in at-risk
communities and spreading misinformation
for the sake of grabbing power and
wielding it against people
um and then a bunch of others i have no
interest in covering this film or
anything to do with matt walsh please
never email me again okay so you get the
idea
now
you may hear all that and think well of
course they responded that way
and in one sense you're right i mean of
course they did but let's not allow them
to hide behind the inevitability of
their own cowardice and intellectual
dishonesty as if they're drawn up by the
forces of fate and have no choice but to
act like a bunch of spineless little
blobfish
the fact is that film critics in mass
are declaring at the outset that they
simply will not even watch
one of the most talked about films of
the year so far one audiences are raving
about and which is indeed a legitimate
and well-made piece of work well made
thanks to our director and producer not
so much to me but it is well made
um it's not unprecedented for a film to
be blackballed to this extent but it is
unusual
because again usually what they'll do is
they don't like the movie for political
reasons is that they'll just pan it
and this reveals once again that
our cultural gatekeepers are totally
beholden to a certain ideological agenda
this doesn't just extend to the people
who create the culture the people who
make the film shows music etc it also
and especially extends the people who
decide which pieces of content in each
of those categories we ought to be
consuming and engaging with
the less cultural institutional
domination works through multiple layers
okay they decide what's made
and if someone manages to make something
that they don't approve of then the
gatekeepers and media can step in to
make sure that nobody hears about it
the good news is that these gatekeepers
have become increasingly impotent as we
develop ways of getting around them and
one very effective way of getting around
them is to do exactly what we're doing
here at the daily wire build our own
institution slowly but surely and
sustain it with the support from the
audience rather than
making ourselves entirely beholden to
advertisers investors shareholders and
so on
and that's just another good reason to
go to what is a woman.com and subscribe
today if you haven't
one other point about the critical
reaction to the film or lack thereof
is that it perfectly illustrates the
point of the film itself the left is
terrified
of the movie of the question
of the approach we took
the truth that we brought to bear
see
if they thought that our film could be
easily debunked
then they'd watch it and they'd debunk
it
they love doing that
you know if they really thought it was a
bunch of transphobic nonsense as they
claim then they would watch it and they
would just they would
point out all of the nonsense in the
movie
if they really thought it was nothing
but a bunch of ignorant bigotry
they would delight in pointing out all
the ways that such is the case
they'd go through it with a fine-toothed
comb john oliver would do a whole show
dissecting it playing clips making
snarky comments
but he can't do that none of them can
because there's no rescuing the people
who made fools of themselves in the film
there's no defending gender ideology in
general
there's no way for them to answer the
question without destroying their own
worldview in the process
now at some level they know that the
film is successful in debunking gender
ideology because at some level they know
that gender ideology is a flimsily
constructed tower of jenga blocks
wobbling in the breeze and ready to fall
over if just one block is removed and
with our film we're going for the block
away at the base of the tower the blocks
the other blocks are sitting on
which means that the tower is certain to
topple
the left doesn't want to be there to
watch it happen for fear that it will
fall directly on their heads so they
look the other way they run the other
direction they cover their eyes they
close their ears hope that eventually we
all get bored and stop talking about the
fact that their worldview is incoherent
absurd and poisonous to civilization
but we're not going to stop
unfortunately for them
and i have to say i also enjoy the
filmmaking process so much that i don't
plan to stop doing that either it's
pretty fun
i'll give the critics many more movies
which i'm sure that they will pretend
don't exist
they can do that all they want
they're still i must say today canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavovsky our
associate producer is mckenna waters the
show is edited by robbie dantzler our
audio is mixed by mike coromina and hair
and makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire
[Music]